muy buenos días hasta ahora sabemos que
murió una persona siete heridos dos de
ellas de gravedad un hombre y una mujer
hemos escuchado hace unos momentos al
superintendente en jefe que asegura que
no fue un ataque terrorista pero sí un
ataque aleatorio esto significa que hay
un sospechoso de esta serie de
apuñalamientos en la ciudad inglesa de
birmingham hay una investigación que ha
abierto la policía por homicidio por
asesinato la zona está acordonada en el
centro de la ciudad de birmingham
sabemos que es la segunda más grande de
inglaterra después de londres así que
hasta estos momentos la policía está
recomendando a la gente mantenerse
alerta seguir su vida cotidiana pero
mantenerse alerta porque esta persona
este sospechoso está fugitivo aún no ha
habido arrestos y en un principio se
sospechaba por el alcance de los
apuñalamientos que habían sido
enfrentamientos entre pandillas sin
embargo esta mañana
de los west midlands ha dicho que se
trata de un solo individuo un sospechoso
que salió a realizar esta este serie de
ataques en el centro de la ciudad donde
hay muchos bares y restaurantes ya se
podrán imaginar la cantidad de gente que
salió el sábado por la noche y la
madrugada de este domingo a divertirse
ahora que las medidas de relajamiento se
han se han hecho mucho mucho más se han
relajado las medidas de descongelamiento